je vous accompagne
[Musique]
venir à l'école pour un rendez-vous
médical c'est ce qui se passe
régulièrement à l'école Henri Beaulieu
et rejoindre sa mère venue elle aussi
pour rencontrer le pédiatre et la
travailleuse sociale et aux besoins
d'autres professionnels
Yasmine a été suivi en orthophonie je me
sens de plus en plus mieux genre avant
quand j'étais comme coincé en me
remarquait pas
de la vie de l'enfant
outre la table d'examen la salle
réservée à la clinique de l'école est
loin du décor réceptisé d'un bureau
médical on comprend beaucoup mieux
certaines problématiques quand on parle
aux enseignants parce que là on a un
accès direct j'ai assez normalement il
faut prendre le téléphone pour parler
enseignant c'est quasiment impossible
c'est toujours des paroles rapportées
tandis qu'ici on a l'enseignant qui va
venir pendant la réunion à partir de ce
local subventionné par le Centre de
Services scolaire Marguerite Bourgeois
on organise aussi d'autres services pour
les élèves
[Musique]
comme la musique au thérapie
ici à l'école le centre de pédiatrie
sociale de Saint-Laurent s'occupe de 20
à 30 élèves par an et parfois c'est
au-delà du niveau primaire
très stressé très réservé en fait je
stressais pour rien quoi maintenant je
suis plus détendu et maintenant ben je
peux jouer devant des gens Lauriane peut
continuer à voir le musicothérapeute
même si elle est au secondaire
maintenant je parle avec
qui je pourrais pas parler d'autres
personnes et tout ça et après ben on va
dire faire d'un instrument mais moi par
exemple passer la batterie et ça
m'aidera à me défouler quoi surtout de
aller faire face avant que c'était de
performance pour que on peut s'arrêter
de saboter des examens puis pas avoir
trop peur de faire des communications
orales par exemple la proximité avec les
familles du quartier et la raison d'être
de la clinique je cherche un marrant
c'est un secteur enclavé il y a très peu
de service qui est proposé aux familles
aux enfants et c'est pourtant des
familles qui vivent dans des grandes
vulnérabilités le système d'éducation on
a le système de santé mais la connexion
entre les deux le lien entre les deux
souvent est absent face aux différents
troubles d'anxiété d'apprentissage de
comportement ou de déficit de
l'attention la direction de l'école ne
se passerait plus de la présence de la
clinique entre ces murs c'est
l'impression d'avoir un pouvoir sur le
développement global de l'enfant pas
seulement son développement académique
de par ce lien-là que j'ai avec les
intervenants qui sont des pédiatres
c'est ça le pouvoir aussi d'accélérer
les choses nous nous sommes là vraiment
pour essayer de trouver le couloir le
plus facile pour essayer de chercher les
services qui est plus nécessaire et
adapté à la famille je pense que on fait
vraiment une différence dans ce sens là
j'aurais pris un an ça aurait pris deux
ans qui sait tandis que là c'est un
enfant qui va être référé en l'espace de
quelques mois
parmi une quarantaine de centres de
pédiatrie sociale bien peu on l'avantage
dans une école pourtant le modèle fait
ses preuves